what i want to do in this video is just
a little bit of practice of converting
between the different number systems so
let's just start with a decimal number
so literally just the number
31 and let's see if we can represent
that in binary and hexadecimal so in
binary you always want to think about
since we're doing it in base 2 that's
what binary is what is the largest power
of 2 that is divisible into 31 and you
might want to visualize those dots like
we did in the last video because you're
trying to divide it into kind of the
least the smallest number of if you view
the money analogy of of kind of currency
or of kind of of of of different units
of currency so in here the units of
currency or the units of place value are
the powers of two so what's this the
largest power of two that is divisible
into this so two to the fifth power
which is 32 is not divisible into this
so two to the fourth power two times two
times two times two sixteen is so how
many 16s are over here so we have one
sixteen
so if we go into so let me draw it this
way so let me draw the places is the
sixteenths place this is the eighth
place this is the fourth place this is
the two's place and this is the ones
place so we we definitely can fit one 16
in here so let me write it this way this
right here is the sixteens place
and this is obviously let me put in
quotes because i just wrote it in base
ten so there's one 16 here
and then we're going to have 15 left
over so you're going to have 15 left
over let me write it this way so 15
left
over
so how many see so what notice the next
largest 16 obviously doesn't go into
this so what's the next largest power of
2 that goes into 15 well 8 goes into 15
once so you have 1 8
so you have 1 8 let me just all do it in
blue
so you have 1 8
and then if you have 1 8 how much you're
going to have left over this 15 you're
going to have 7 left over so then you're
going to have 7 left over
and so 8 doesn't go into it let's go to
the fours you're going to have 1 4
and then if you have that 1 4 you now
have three left over three left
and then we could take out one two
so then we'll have one left
we'll have one left
and that one we can just represent it as
one in the ones place it's literally one
one one one one in binary now in
hexadecimal what's the largest power of
16 that is divisible into 31
well just 16 is 256 isn't so 16 goes
into 31 one time so let me make it clear
here's our 16's place
that's our 16's place this is our ones
place
so 16 goes into 31 one time so we have
116 and then you're going to have 15
left over 15 left
15 left over and you might say wait how
do i represent 15 in one space over here
but remember we're dealing with
hexadecimal hexadecimals have digits
have representations for numbers all the
way up through 15. let me remind you you
know you can start zero one you keep
going you go eight
nine then for ten you have a for eleven
you have b
for 12 you have c
d
e
f f is the equivalent of 15. so if you
want to represent 15 ones you literally
just put an f here so this might not
look like a number to you but in
hexadecimal it is one f this is this is
hexadecimal 4 31. you have 1 16 and you
have 15
ones and this is the symbol for 15.
let's do a couple of other examples and
we'll convert between the different
number systems let me think of a binary
number so let's say i just have
one
one
zero zero zero
zero one
one so this seems pretty complicated but
if we just break it down by the number
spaces it shouldn't be too bad
so we have one one so this is one
so that you could just call that one we
have one two right this is the two's
place now actually let me write the
places here i think that'll help clarify
things when we're doing this conversion
or at least as we start this is the ones
place the two's place the fourth place
eighth place sixteens
thirty seconds or thirty-two place
sixty-four and then one
so you have one one which is just one
you have one two which if we wanted to
represent it in base two we would write
or or a larger bait not base two in base
10 or larger base than binary you would
call that so that you have that's two
then you have 0 4 0 8 0 16 0 32's you do
have 164
and you do have one 128
1 128 so if you wanted to represent this
in decimal it's going to be 128 plus 64
plus 2 plus 1 so let me add that up so
if we have 128 plus 64
plus 2
plus 1
plus 2 plus 1 you're going to have
you are going to have 8 plus 4 is 12
plus 2 is 14 plus 1 is 15.
1 plus 2 is 3 plus 6 is 9
and then you bring down the 1. so this
is this 1 1 0 zero zero zero one one in
base 10 in decimal in a decimal number
system is
195. so how would we write the same
number in base 16
in base 16.
so the way to think about it the way to
think about it actually there's a trick
to go straight from base 2 to base 16
but i won't do that just yet
but the way to think about it is
let's go let's take what's the largest
power of 16 that goes into 195
256 doesn't go into it so 16 is the
largest power so how many times does 16
go into 195 let's just do the math 16
goes into 195
goes into 19 once 1 times 16 is 16
subtract you get a 3
bring down the 5. 16 goes into 35 two
times 2 times 16 is
32 then you subtract you have a
remainder of 3.
so you have 12 16s plus 3 ones so let me
write it again 195 you could write this
as
you could write this as 12 16s
12 16s and then plus
three
ones right 16 goes into 195 12 times so
you have 12 16s and then you have three
ones so in the 16s place
this might be a little bizarre but the
more practice we get will actually make
a lot of sense and the sixteenths place
which is right over here you're going to
run or write 12. but we're going to
write 12 using our new digits we don't
want to write based we want we want a
symbol for it we don't want to use our
base 10 symbols right over here so let's
remind ourselves a corresponds to 10 in
base 10
b corresponds to 1 1 in base 10 or 11
c is 12 d is 13 e is 14 f is 15. so to
represent 12 in base 16 you use
you use c so you have c 16s and you have
three ones so once again this might this
looks more like a a gate at an airport
but this is actually a number in base
16. c3 this is telling you you have 12
this is a symbol for 12 in base 16. you
have 12 16s because this is the 16th
place and you have three ones 12 16s and
you if you multiply 12 times 16 and then
you get to 192 you add 3 you get to 195.
so hopefully you found that interesting